when you made
simple life by the way i love simple i
think simple life is one of the great
shows it looks like you had fun in spite
of it right it was so much fun you know
i had no idea what i was getting myself
into since this was like one of the
first reality shows
yeah i had never been on camera before i
didn't really know what to expect
but i'm so happy that i did it with
nicole because we were best friends
since we're two years old
and we just
i don't know we just have fun no matter
what we do or where we were so i'm so
happy it was her that was with me along
for that whole ride because it was just
hilarious the whole time there's no one
funnier i was just laughing the whole
time and
we met a lot of really sweet and cool
people and got to like go all over
america and it was awesome what did you
travel in did you actually travel on it
like how did they get you around the
country well the first season we were
just at one house in arkansas so we just
had our pink pickup truck and then for
the other seasons like we had another
pink pickup truck that had
like a little like trailer airstream
attached to it
uh that i had to drive which was pretty
difficult
you didn't grow up driving an uh an
airstream trail
through the streets of manhattan people
i don't think
realize
making reality television
i i did a show with my sons where we
chased around supernatural tales it was
kind of like
i don't know picture anthony bourdain
parts unknown meets scooby-doo
called the low files it was basically an
excuse for me to hang out with my boys
and like
you know go up into the mountains and
look for ufos or whatever it was super
fun but boy you work hard you work your
ass off yeah it's it seems like it's
easy like oh there's no script and they
just throw the camera i've never worked
harder never worked longer
um it's a totally different vibe and
that was one of those you say the
original
reality shows yes
you know back then it was we were
shooting 24 hours a day and
they were very strict like they
literally took away our phones they
didn't want us having any outside
distractions
they told all of the crew members do not
like talk back to them so if we asked
for something or tried to like
communicate with them they would just
not say anything so nicole and i were
like really on our own it wasn't like we
were stopping and they were telling us
what to do it was just all real
holy
smokes
did you ever try to like blink in morris
code get me out of here to like
second ad or the director photography
get me
there are some times where we were just
like oh my god like we want to go home
there's we're just having fomo of
everything happening in la and
it's so boring sometimes and the dad
gave us like a strict curfew and
we were not into that so we would sneak
out at night and there's there was no
clubs hardly there was like these really
random bars
like cowboy bars and places that we went
to
um so yeah the nightlife out there was
definitely uh
not la